zu den geheimnisvollsten kunden und
rätseln der archäologie gehören
sicherlich die berühmten boden
zeichnungen der nasca kultur in der
wüste von süd bewahren sie etwa als
landebahnen für außerirdische gedacht
oder nutzte die nasca kultur sie damals
als gigantischen kalender in der
wissenschaft hat sich jetzt an der
theorie zum sinn und zweck der etwa 1500
mysteriösen geoglyphen verfestigt was
die forschung heutzutage zu den
gigantischen tierbildern denkt und ob
damit tatsächlich das große rätsel der
archäologie gelüftet ist jetzt in kriegs
und science fiction herzlich willkommen
die fläche auf denen die gigantischen
tierbilder im boden zu sehen sind
umfasst schätzungen zufolge fast 500
quadratkilometer wenn man mit dem
flugzeug über die wüste perus fliegt er
kennt man dort zum beispiel eine spinne
einen affen oder einen kolibri um die
1500 geo wissen sollen dort zu finden
sein nennt sie die nasca linien benannt
sind die boden zeichnung nach der nasca
kultur die von etwa 200 vor bis 650 nach
christus in dieser region gelebt haben
soll und obwohl das schon so lange her
es gibt es noch immer reichlich
spekulationen um die geoglyphen warum
und wann genau hat die naspa kultur sie
angelegt und wozu wurden die bilder
damals genutzt dazu gibt es jetzt eine
neue erklärung und zwar vom museum
rietberg in zürich bis zum frühjahr
werden hier in einer ausstellung
beispielsweise drohnen bilder dieser
boden zeichnungen gezeigt das museum
bezieht sich unter anderem auf die
forschungsergebnisse vom deutschen
archäologischen institut in
zusammenarbeit mit dem peruanischen
kultusministerium und anderen partnern
stellen grabungen laufen seit 1997 eines
der ergebnisse
die nasca bilder dienten den menschen
damals wohl nicht zum anschauen sondern
zum ablaufen und zwar im rahmen
besonderer rituale dazu heißt es in der
pressemitteilung des rietberger museums
die hochebenen in der wüste zwischen den
bewässerten tälern als wohnort und den
bergen als sitz der götter bilden
zwischen dem leben und dem göttlichen
eine zwischenebene das ist ein idealer
ort für die kontaktaufnahme mit dem
übernatürlichen die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler vermuten also dass
sich die menschen damals auf den bildern
bewegt haben dass sie diese quasi
rituell abgeschrieben sind dazu gab es
wohl musik darauf deuten die funde von
musikinstrumenten wie trommeln und
flöten nehmen rhythmus spielte bei
diesem ritual wo er eine große rolle
zudem konnten archäologie teams grell
bunte keramik nadel linien bergen das
wurde wohl bewusst bei diesen
veranstaltungen zerschlagen
forschungsteams denken dass die menschen
bei diesen ritualen wohl auch
psychoaktive substanzen eingenommen
haben
klingt alles nach richtig fette party
doch die wurden wohl nicht einfach so
ohne grund gefeiert es gibt klima
studien die zeigen
aus dieser region gerade in dieser zeit
extrem trocken wurde das legt nahe dass
die menschen höhere mächte um hilfe
gebeten haben könnte konkret um das
lebensnotwendige wasser die bilder also
eine folge des damaligen klimawandels in
dieser region
man könnte sich die szenerie dann also
in etwa so vorstellen im süden perus
würde es immer heißer und trockener
die nasca sind verzweifelt und so gibt
es jede menge prozession ein priester
geht voran die anderen menschen folgen
ihm
sie schreiten entlang der konturen des
affen der spinne und des kolibris dabei
machen sie musik mit trommeln und
panflöten viele der menschen befinden
sich in einer art heiligem rausch sie
opfern den göttern früchte und andere
symbole für wasser sie alle flehen um
hilfe
wasser wird dringend benötigt doch die
forschungsergebnisse weisen auch noch
auf etwas anderes sind und zwar dass ein
teil dieser geo liefen schon vor der
zeit der nasca kultur angelegt worden
sind und zwar von menschen aus der
gegend des südamerikanischen paracas
quasi die vorläufer der nasca kultur
doch eigentlich ein und dasselbe folgt
demnach ist die paracas kultur um etwa
200 vor christus geendet doch nach
jetzigem wissenstand wurde sie dann zwei
kilometer weiter entfernt weitergeführt
und zwar in form der nasca kultur wenn
auch in leicht abgeänderter form diesen
schluss ziehen die archäologen und
archäologie da sie keine hinweise auf
größere gruppen an neuankömmlingen in
der region finden konnten die geoglyphen
machten jedoch in dieser zeit an
riesigen wandel durch derzeit der
paracas entstanden bilder die nur wenige
meter groß waren die boden zeichnung
wurden mit der zeit immer größer
zudem übertrug die parkas kultur sie aus
der vertikalen in die horizontalen
weiter richtung pampas dass dieser zeit
also 200 vor christus stammt wohl auch
ein rund 60 meter langer orca hier
verschiebt sich das zentrum der kultur
wohl gerade von paragrafen anders kam
ab dieser zeit legten die menschen die
bilder auf den ebenen selbst anderen
nicht mehr an der abbruchkante der
pampas zudem gingen sie immer mehr in
richtung geometrischer form wie trapez
oder linien bis zu mehreren kilometern
länge ist wirklich total beeindruckend
wie
und was kulturen zu entwickeln und
welche rätsel sie uns dann manchmal
aufgeben wenn er kein video zu diesen
themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht dem genau auf die glocke nur dann
werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos
informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken aliens zehn gründe für ihre
existenz da geht es um zehn hinweise und
indizien für aliens das spielt nasca
auch eine rolle aber das ist ja nun
widerlegt da bleibt nur noch neun aber
die sind auch ziemlich spannend
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran